Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Du möchtest, hast du Themenvorschläge? Ich habe gestern auf Twitter schon gefragt,
hat jemand Themenvorschläge?
Eine Frage war, was trägt Wolfgang beim Sport?
Ich glaube, das interessiert die Leute jetzt gerade gar nicht.
Trainingsanzug.
Nein, ich glaube, es interessiert die Leute eher, dass wir keinen Finanzminister mehr haben.
Haben wir einen Verlust?
Auf keinen Fall. Ich hoffe, er beantragt kein Bürgergeld.
Kein Finanzminister ist kein Verlust.
Kein Finanzminister ist kein Verlust. Das ist ganz deutlich so zu sehen.
Ich bin nicht wahnsinnig überrascht, aber bin überrascht darüber,
wie schnell es dann plötzlich ging.
Wie schnell es sich dann hochgeschaukelt hat, so an einem späten Nachmittag bis hin zum Abend.
Und ich bin entsetzt darüber, dass es jetzt so eskaliert ist.
Allerdings habe ich auf dein Geheiß hin einen Podcast mir angehört und angesehen,
in dem Christian Lindner zu Gast war, nämlich im Hotel Matze.
Und ich verfolge hin und wieder Hotel Matze.
Manchmal sind Politiker da, dann ist mir das oft sehr menschelnd und das interessiert
mich dann nicht so sehr. Dann ist jemand da wie Barbara Bleich,
die wunderbar aus ihrem Leben und aus ihrer Philosophie erzählen kann und man
merkt, tatsächlich entsteht ein Gespräch zwischen zwei Menschen oder H.P.
Kerkeling, da findet das dann auch statt, obwohl es zwei Medienprofis sind,
sieht man plötzlich, dass sich da Menschen verständigen, nochmal einen Begriff definieren,
bereit sind zu zögern, um nachzudenken, um dann näher zu einer wahrheitsgemäßen Antwort zu kommen.
Und all das ist das Interview mit Christian Lindner nicht.
Man sieht das und ist wirklich erschrocken darüber.
Und ich muss mich ja hier vorsichtig ausdrücken, weil wir haben hier sehr viel
darüber gesprochen, wie Trump so tickt.
Ja, Lindner hat einen anderen Stil als Trump, aber wir haben schon sehr viel
über die besondere psychische Struktur von Machtmenschen gesprochen und man
braucht glaube ich nur mal drei, vier Minuten in dieses Interview reinzuschalten,
um zu sehen.
Hier sitzt ein Mensch, der einen Charakter hat, mit dem man eigentlich nichts
zu tun haben will und zwar nicht auf einer politischen Ebene,
nicht auf einer privaten Ebene, auf gar keiner Ebene.
Ich bin so entsetzt darüber, was ich da sehe, also wie sich dort ein Mensch
verhält, wie präpotent er dort sitzt,
wie er keinerlei Zweifel an sich aufkommen lässt, wie er überhaupt alles herunterbügelte
und man muss wissen, Matze Hilscher ist ja jemand, der wohlgesonnen einem jeden Gast gegenüber sitzt.
Das ist vielleicht manchmal zu wohl geworden, nach meinem Geschmack.
Also man kann eigentlich aus einem Matze-Hielscher-Gespräch gar nicht schlecht herauskommen.
Es ist eigentlich der Ort, an dem man sich wieder von einer guten Seite zeigen kann.
Also wenn man irgendwas Böses gemacht hat, geht man zum Matze-Hielscher und
sagt, ich bin aber jetzt ein anderer geworden oder so.
Und man hat einen Christian Lindner da, der wirklich völlig frei dreht und ich
fand es beängstigend zu sehen,
dass wir von einem solchen Mann regiert werden und war gestern tatsächlich,
egal was da jetzt kommen möge,
erleichtert, dass dieses Spiel ein Ende hat.
Und wenn ich daran denke, dass man als Bundeskanzler mit Christian Lindner regelmäßig
zu tun hat, in einem Raum sitzen muss, dann weiß ich gar nicht, wie man das aushält.
Ja, wir haben es ja schon da liegen, man sieht es auch im Bild,
das Verlustbuch von Andreas Reckwitz.
Zumindest thematisch, das erste Wort des Buches ist ein Aufhänger,
ein Anlass, sozusagen um über alles zu reden.
Denn Verluste werden doch hart verrechnet. Jetzt hast du schon sehr ausführlich einen.
Eindruck deines Hörerlebnisses, Lindner bei Matze Hilscher gehört,
ich halte das Gespräch auch für historisch, es erklärt uns vieles,
nicht nur allgemein zuhören, die mit einer Gefühlslage daran gehen wie du und feststellen,
krass, ich höre ihn jetzt sozusagen mal länger als zwei Minuten vom Blatt abgelesen
und ich kann es nicht glauben, was ich hier fühle. Ja.
So, wir benutzen das jetzt aber als Klammer. Also wir hören Clips daraus gleich,
denn wir müssen erst erklären, warum wir uns besonders für dieses Interview da interessieren.
Zum einen ist die große Fragestellung von, wir haben ja sein Buch gelesen,
im Grunde gut, in der er die Frage stellt, wenn die Menschen doch im Grunde
gut sind, warum spült ausgerechnet der politische Betrieb so viele Egoisten,
manchmal populär, zuschauerisch als Narzissen, noch gesteigert an die Spitze.
Warum werden ausgerechnet da, wo das Gemeinwohl angeblich im Mittelpunkt steht,
so oft nur partikulare Interessen, versteckt, offen formuliert,
durchgeprügelt, wie auch immer?
Diese Frage kann man sehr gut beantworten, gerade jetzt.
Nicht nur, weil wir dieses Matze-Hilscher-Gespräch hätten, haben,
sondern auch noch durch die Ereignisse gestern.
Also wir haben auf offener Bühne gesehen, dass ein Bundeskanzler Bilanz zieht
eines Verhaltens, das wir schon lange so beobachtet haben, aber das vom Bundeskanzler
versteckt werden musste.
Ja, es war eine permanente Devianz da, über die man nicht gesprochen hat.
Ja, dieses Statement von Scholz gestern ist also stellvertretend für aufgestaute
Wut, Entrüstung aufgrund von Beobachtungen über drei Jahre, die aus ihm herausbrach.
Er hat Christian Lindner mehrfach beim Namen genannt.
Er hat von betrügerischen, verräterischen, ich überspitze jetzt so ein bisschen,
Verhalten vor Ort gesprochen.
Absprachen, die auf Handschlag zugesagt wurden, nur um direkt aus dem Raum zu
gehen und in die Kamera zu sagen, das sind die größten Idioten,
ich weiß es besser, die Absprache war falsch, wir werden Prüfaufträger und so
weiter. Wir werden alles wieder torbedürftigen.
Und jetzt ist das, was gestern passiert ist, aber nur, also es klappte nur,
weil gestern noch anderes passiert ist.
Also Trump hat die Wahl gewonnen und Christian Lindner wurde entlassen und es
gab so einen Tenor, der sich fragte, musste das jetzt auch noch sein?
Brauchten wir nicht gerade jetzt Stabilität? Und ich würde sagen,
nein, nur weil das eine passierte, war das andere möglich.
Also es war sozusagen schicksalhaft verwoben, ein Tag, der es fehlte nur noch, dass sie bis zum 9.
November warten, so, dass alles passierte.
Aber ich will es mal in wirklich ein Bild bringen. In Amerika hat sich ein partikularistisches,
ideologiegetriebenes Interesse direkt in die Macht katapultiert.
Und damit meine ich gar nicht so sehr Trump, denn der ist einfach doof,
sondern ich meine Elon Musk.
Elon Musk ist jetzt der quasi Präsident der Vereinigten Staaten.
Er ist nicht einfach Steve Bannon, der einfach gefeuert werden kann.
Das werden wir noch sehen. Wer weiß, ob nicht Trump dann in drei Monaten das alles anders geht.
Trump kann sich nicht gegen ihn entscheiden, weil er kann ihn wirklich nicht kündigen.
Das stimmt, ja.
Weil Elon Musk nimmt alles mit, was Trump wichtig ist.
Den Zugriff auf die Technologie, den Zugriff auf die Märkte und den Zugriff auf das Publikum.
Elon Musk gehört Starlink, Elon Musk, also das ist quasi die Erpressertechnologie
für Taiwan, China und Putin.
Twitter, E-Mobilität wird wichtig werden.
Genau, das sind die Märkte. Wenn du dich gegen China behaupten willst,
ich habe die Fabriken dafür.
So viel zu liberalen Demokratie.
Genau, und wenn du wissen willst, was deine Leute denken, brauchst du Twitter.
Also Elon Musk hat Donald Trump auf eine Art und Weise in der Tasche,
wie wir es bisher nur kannten, als sich die Kaiser und Fürsten,
Könige, die großen Dynastien, die über Jahrhunderte regierten,
plötzlich als, achso, ich habe Schulden bei den Fuggers.
Zack, die ganze Logik der Welt umgedreht, die moderne Stadte,
der Kapitalismus begann und so weiter und so fort. Das ist jetzt dieser Moment.
Also man darf das sowieso nicht geringschätzen. Also wir haben in Amerika dieses
Heranstürmen eines partikularen, ideologiegetriebenen,
egozentrischen, im Grunde schlechte Seite des Menschen ist jetzt in Amerika installiert.
Und Olaf Scholz hat gestern genau das bei Lindner kritisiert und als Begründung
genannt, weshalb er gehen muss. Ja.
Also die Ampel hatte gestern,
in ihrer letzten Viertelstunde ihren Humanmöhepunkt sozusagen.
Und das war ja auch anzumerken, Olaf Scholz. Er hat hier die beste Rede seines
Lebens gehalten. Ganz klar.
Sowohl was die emotionale Tonalität stimmte, die Aussagen stimmten.
Es war eine Rede, die sagte, wir haben jetzt eine Krise.
Und welche Krise ist gemeint? Nun, wir haben die Wirtschaftskrise.
Wir haben aber vor allem, wir sind dann wenige Stunden, nachdem das Wahlergebnis
bekannt geworden ist, an einem Punkt angelangt, an dem Trump erneut im Weißen Haus ist.
Man sich also fragt, was wird geschehen mit Europa, mit Deutschland.
Und wir haben nichts anderes dann erlebt als eine FDP an der Spitze Christian
Lindner, die einfach nur ihren Trip weiter verfolgt.
Und deswegen will ich auch hier ausdrücklich allen Journalisten,
die zuhören, sagen, wer noch Marie-Agnes Strack-Zimmermann interviewt, ist unseriös.
Die FDP scheißt auf die Ukrainer, ob die in einen harten Winter gehen oder sonst
irgendetwas. Der FDP ist auch egal, was jetzt gerade mit NATO und sonst was ist.
Das soll jetzt Scholz klären und vielleicht findet er ein Einverständnis mit Merz.
Der FDP ist alles scheißegal, ladet Strack Zimmermann nicht mehr ein.
Sie ist nicht bereit, sie wurde auch gestern interviewt, irgendeinen Fehler
einzugestehen. Sie macht denselben Move wie Christian Lindner.
Es ist unseriös mit diesen Leuten noch über Verantwortung und schon gerade geopolitische
Verantwortung zu sprechen.
Ja. Wolf Schmiese hat im August, ich habe diesen Clip gestern nochmal getwittert,
im Heute-Journal gesagt, in der SPD warten einige auf den Wahlsieg Donald Trumps,
weil dann klar ist, die Ukraine ist verloren.
Kein weiterer Euro und Dollar kommt aus Amerika und wir wissen jetzt,
Die Ideologie, die jetzt in Amerika an der Macht ist, ist so scharf,
dass sie auch die eigene Rüstungsindustrie unter den Bus wirft.
Wir haben das gehört von Tucker Carlson, lieber verliere ich mein Haus zu Hause,
als dass irgendein Afrikaner kommt und mir erklärt, das ist nicht mehr dein Land. Ja.
So, die eigene Rüstungsindustrie ist dieses eigene Haus.
Ja.
Lieber zieht man sich aus der Welt zurück und sagt, lasst uns Bomben bauen,
aber hier zu Hause behalten, bevor auch nur und so weiter.
Deswegen, ja, die FDP ist, so wie du es gesagt hast, der ist alles scheißegal.
Ja. Und Scholz und Lindner, sag ich mal so, Scholz hat gestern ein gut vorbereitetes
Statement gehalten und Scholz hat die Schuldenbremse, also er hat gesagt,
es ist an der Schuldenbremse zerbrochen.
Ja.
Zwei Punkte. Lindner bezog sich genau auf diese beiden Punkte.
Er hat gesagt, Scholz hat ein erstaunlich gut vorbereitetes Statement gehalten,
wo ich mir denke, ah ja, Christian Lindner glaubt gerade, indem er Olaf Scholz
Professionalität unterstellt, kann er ihm schaden.
Ja.
Das verstehe ich nicht. Und Lindner hat nochmal auf die Schuldenbremse auch
abgestellt, im Sinne von, ich erkenne diese Notlage nicht an.
Und sagte, er hätte dann doch einen Amtseid geschworen und das hat ja nichts
mit dem Amtseid zu tun, dass man an die Schuldenbremse, also mir ist neu,
dass man sich vereidigen lässt in Deutschland und dann auch noch auf die Schuldenbremse schwört.
Also das ist alles total hanebüchen. Das heißt, Scholz und Lindner haben gestern
quasi inhaltlich dasselbe Statement abgegeben mit den zwei gleichen Schwerpunkten.
Aber Lindner hat es aus einer praktikulistischen Interessenlage.
Ich kämpfe für die drei Prozent, die mich noch wählen und das sind halt die
Leute, die was zu verlieren haben, gehalten und scheiß auf die Ukraine.
Und Scholz hat dasselbe gesagt, nur mit umgedrehten Vorzeichen und etwas überlegt.
Wie schon gesagt, angenehmer, professioneller, sodass wir es auch verstehen.
Er sprach von Verantwortung, er hat die Ukraine mit in den Blick genommen und
zugleich aber auch die wirtschaftliche Situation in Deutschland.
Er sagte, ich will nicht das eine gegen das andere ausspielen,
das nämlich hat die FDP vor.
Und das war ja immer der Vorwurf so vieler Journalisten zu sagen,
ja Alice Weidel und Sarah Wagenknecht, die spielen die Ukraine-Hilfe gegen den Sozialstaat aus.
Weil sie sagen, entweder das eine oder das andere.
Und dann habe ich immer gedacht, bei dieser Argumentation, die Journalisten
so vorwurfsvoll vorbrachten, ja, das machen die beiden, aber die FDP macht das ja die ganze Zeit.
Die FDP sagt ja, so viel Geld ist da, wem wollte das nun geben?
Und da sagt Olaf Scholz, jetzt wird man sehen, was daraus folgt,
wir wollen jetzt auch nicht glorifizieren hier, sagt aber Olaf Scholz,
nein, wir müssen die Schuldenbremse lockern, damit beides geht und es nicht
eine Entweder-Oder-Logik ist.
Und der Witz ist ja wirklich, dass Lindner in seinem Statement sofort darauf
eingeht, du hast es schon gesagt, dass Scholz sein Statement vorbereitet hat.
Besser ist, wenn der Regierung zerbricht, dass man das kurz vorbereitet.
Es ist so, dass diese Leute ja wissen, wie Lindner tickt und ich könnte mir
sogar vorstellen, dass hier Wolfgang Schmidt oder so auch mal Marce Hilscher
mal da reingeschaltet hat und hat gesagt, hier Olaf,
der dreht völlig frei, guck mal hier kurz rein und dann wird Olaf Scholz gesagt
haben, bereitet mal ein Statement vor, man weiß ja nicht, was der am Mittwoch vorhat.
Das ist professionelles Handeln und ich hoffe sehr, also du weißt,
was ich sozialpolitisch und so alles jetzt Schlechtes über Scholz sagen könnte,
habe ich aber jetzt gar keine Lust zu gerade, sondern ich will nochmal ganz deutlich sagen.
Ich halte Scholz für die geopolitische Lage, für den idealen Kanzler gerade.
Ich finde seine Besonnenheit sehr gut. Ich glaube, diese Besonnenheit wird auch
wichtig sein in der Konfrontation mit Trump.
Das wird nicht mehr so gut funktionieren wie mit Biden, wo beide sehr besonnen
aufgetreten sind. Und ich glaube aber, dass Scholz hier zeigt, der hat Nerven.
Und ich habe große Angst vor einem Kanzler Friedrich Merz.
Aus sozialpolitischen Gründen natürlich, aus ganz, ganz vielen Gründen.
Vor allem aber, weil wir wissen, dass Merz für Taurus Lieferung war,
Merz uns noch in andere geopolitische Kriege verwickeln könnte,
Merz einen Blick auf den Nahostkonflikt hat, der so idiotisch ist,
dass man es kaum in Worte fassen kann.
Und dass das mit Merz wirklich eine große Gefahr ist, zumal auch die CDU immer
mehr sich versucht, den Republikanern, den Trump-Republikanern anzunähern.
Jens Spahn läuft da schon ganz voran vorweg und deswegen ist das eine sehr,
sehr große Gefahr, die sich da gerade ergibt und deswegen steht ja auch noch
im Raum, ob diese Pragmatik, die Scholz jetzt vorschlägt, auch dann in Zusammenarbeit
mit der Union wirklich stattfinden kann.
Oder ob die Union, man hat ja schon Tweets von Spahn und Josef Winkel und so
weiter gesehen, Johannes Winkel,
ob die Union überhaupt noch bereit ist,
eine vernünftige Politik zu machen, etwas Verantwortung zu übernehmen oder ob
die genauso einen Ego-Trip verfolgen werden, wie die FDP das gerade tut.
Sagen wir es mal so, Jens Spahn und...
Winkel machen jetzt schon Wahlkampf, wo Merz noch staatspolitisch verantwortlich
Ruhe hält. Kann sein, dass er,
nach dem Tweet gestern von Spahn ihn nochmal ein bisschen zurückpfeift oder
sowas, aber wir wissen jetzt in welche Richtung das geht.
Wir müssen aber noch einen Schritt zurück machen, denn du hast jetzt schon das
Merz, also Blackrock wird Bundeskanzler Szenario.
Bis dahin passiert ja etwas. Also bis Mitte Januar möchte ja Scholz in der ersten,
äh, wie nennt man es, Bundestagssitzung dann die Vertrauensfrage stellen.
Er hat keine Mehrheit, also wissen wir, okay, dann wird ein Wahltermin bekannt gegeben.
Bis dahin, ich habe hier einen Text heute in der Lesung im Salon,
der von drei Personen handelt.
Fabian Billing, Michael Briegel und Stefan Scheible.
Kennst du einen von den dreien?
Nein.
Wahrscheinlich niemand, ich kannte sie auch nicht. Ich sagte,
wer sie sind. Die Deutschlandchefs von McKinsey.
BCG, also der Boston Consulting Group und Roland Berger. Das sind die drei größten
Berater. Zumindest Roland Berger macht einen Milliardenumsatz.
So. Nun ist es so, ich wollte diesen Text eigentlich mitbringen,
der unter ferner Lieven irgendwo im Handelsblatt und so weiter,
um mich darüber lustig zu machen.
Weil die nämlich mehrere Sachen schreiben, wie zum Beispiel es braucht jetzt
ein Konvent aus Schulz und Merz, der noch im November tagt, um bis Jahresende
Beschlüsse zu fassen, damit das nächste Jahr gut starten kann.
Sie haben sozusagen das Ampelende nicht eingeläutet, aber gesagt, so wird es ja eh nichts.
Also sollen Scholz und Merz und dann schreiben sie und die Regierungschefs der
Ampelparteien, jetzt wissen wir, es gibt keine Ampelpartei mehr.
Also der Text ist vor dieser Geschichte.
Genau, Lindner ist jetzt aussortiert und der Text, über den ich mich lustig
machen wollte, ist jetzt das wahrscheinlichste Szenario, hinter dem sich Merz
und Scholz versammeln könnten noch im November, um dann kurz vor Weihnachten
so einen Plan zu schmieden.
Eine der zentralen Aussagen, aber eben nicht nur, ist wirklich Aussetzen der Schuldenbremse.
Das heißt, es gibt tatsächlich einen großen Dritten, der jetzt die Agenda vorgibt
und beiden politischen Parteien die Möglichkeit gibt zu sagen,
es ist ja nicht unser Plan, wir machen jetzt keine Zugeständnisse an den,
sondern an den großen anderen.
Die Vernunft, die Berater haben gesagt, also machen wir das mal.
Und wir haben ja immer gesagt, das mit der Schuldenbremse ist ganz heikel deshalb,
weil man diese Zweidrittelmehrheit bezeichnet.
Die noch da ist.
Die noch da ist, ganz richtig.
Nicht nach der nächsten Bundestagswahl.
Die kann nur jetzt da sein. Nur jetzt kann diese Verbindung entstehen.
Und das ist eigentlich jetzt dann das große Glück vielleicht in der Sache.
Wer weiß, wohin uns dann dieses Schuldenmachen führt im Sinne von Aufrichtung oder so.
Aber das ist das große Glück dieser Situation, dass Lindner jetzt einfach da raus ist.
Und wenn die FDP ja noch ein paar vernünftige Leute hätte, was offenbar nicht
der Fall ist, Dann würden die ja jetzt eine Rebellion starten gegen Finanzminister
Lindner und würde sagen, schau mal, was hast du denn eigentlich angerichtet die ganze Zeit?
Wir sind aus Landtagen rausgeflogen, wir sind unter 5% gerade,
willst du jetzt wieder einen Schwarz-Weiß-Wahlkampf machen und ein paar markige
Slogans im Porsche von dir geben und dann wird das schon was werden?
Also es müsste quasi so eine Rebellion der Anständigen in der FDP geben.
Ich vermute nur, der Anstand ist so den Verlust durchgegangen,
Verlust, dass da nicht mehr viel zu holen ist.
Denn dann könnte man tatsächlich die Vertrauensfrage stellen und sagen,
ja, wir machen es weiter, aber ohne Christian Lindner und ohne vielleicht Stark-Watzinger oder so.
Also mal gucken, ob es jetzt in den nächsten acht Wochen eine Mini-Zeitlicher-Dimension-Kroko
plötzlich gibt, um nochmal grundlegende Pfeile einzuschlagen und danach erst
den offenen Wahlkampf zu erklären.
Ich finde, Scholz hat es jetzt gut vorbereitet, dass plötzlich diese drei Beraterchefs
da im Hintergrund so eine wichtige Rolle spielen. Keine Ahnung,
wie das mit allem zusammenhängt.
Es kommt auf jeden Fall aus der falschen Richtung. Wir gehen den Text nachher
durch. Das sind insgesamt 93 Seiten, die da geschrieben wurden.
Also es ist nicht ohne. Wir gehen aber nur die Handblattberichterstattung durch,
denn den Originaltext habe ich gar nicht gefunden.
Wer weiß, wo der abgeblieben ist.
Und genau, jetzt zu, ah ne, eine Sache will ich noch sagen.
Bevor wir jetzt gleich Lindners Personality untersuchen.
Es gab gestern Zoff auf Twitter bei der Frage, wie verarbeiten wir das Wahlergebnis
in Amerika nicht intellektuell, nicht inhaltlich, sondern emotional.
Das muss ja irgendwo im moralischen Kompass platziert werden,
damit Norden wieder Norden ist und so.
Und was ich sehr betrüblich fand, ist, dass ausgerechnet Wolfgang Michael in
so einen Tenor einschwang, der behauptete...
Alle in der ARD und alle im ZDF hätten dieselben Fehler gemacht wie 2016.
Und ich will nochmal umrahmen, 2016 wurde für drei Uhr eine komplett weiblich
besetzte Runde als Dreiviertelstunde Panel-Diskussion angesetzt,
um abzufeiern, dass Hillary Clinton die Wahl gewinnt.
Und es wurde zu Recht danach kritisiert, dass natürlich klar ist,
dass Frauen, die relativ wenig mit Politik zu tun haben, sondern aus allen Himmelsrichtungen
zusammen, ich weiß nicht mehr genau, wer in der Runde saß,
aber es war nicht das Panel, das qualifiziert war, um uns das amerikanische
Wahlsystem und den Erfolg von Donald Trump zu erklären.
Es gab also ein Misalignment auf Seiten des Journalismus.
Das gab es aber diesmal nicht.
Und ich will es ganz deutlich sagen,
als einer der größten Kritiker dieser Hauptstadtjournalistenproduktion,
wir haben es im Fernsehpodcast ausführlich begleitet, wir haben es hier auch besprochen.
Ich erinnere daran, dass wir selbst im vergangenen Podcast hier vor einer Woche
die Israel- und der Ostberichterstattung des Heute-Journals und der Tagesthemen nicht schlecht fanden.
Denn die Berichterstattung darüber, dass die israelische Armee Palästinenser
als menschliche Schutzschilder benutzt und so weiter, kommt aus der ARD direkt, vom ZDF direkt.
Das ist zwar keine flächendeckende Berichterstattung, aber punktuell findet das dort statt.
Und es ist auch nicht, wie Elmar Thewissen mal bei uns im Augen machen Podcast
erklärte, aber wir haben das doch erklärt im Morgenmagazin, hatten wir auch drei Minuten dazu.
Nein, das ist Berichterstattung aus Tagesthemen und Heute-Journal.
Also es ist im inneren Mainstream.
So und jetzt gab es auf Twitter eine Diskussion darüber, wer hat sich hier wie geirrt.
Und ich will deswegen nochmal ganz klar markieren, die Präferenz für...
Damals Hillary Clinton, heute Kamala Harris oder Joe Biden, gut,
der hat dann auch gewonnen, aber diese Präferenz für diese Kandidaten ist keine Aussage darüber,
wer gewinnt oder irgendein emotionaler Ausbruch im Sinne von schon vorab,
ja, heute Nacht wird sie ja gewinnen und so weiter und dann steht man blöd da,
weil man es plötzlich falsch vorausgesagt hat.
Die Präferenz für einen spezifischen Kandidaten in der Politik ist als Präferenz immer legitim.
Ja, das auf jeden Fall. Und ich würde auch sagen, dass es da diesmal eine große Vorsicht gab.
Egal, wer befragt wurde, wer wird. Ich kann dir ein paar Namen nennen,
aber das sind ja unverbesserlich.
Also Timothy Snyder twitterte in der Nacht, weil wohl, also in der Nacht,
als schon erste Stimmen ausgezählt wurden, dass wohl irgendjemand aus Moskau
irgendwelche Trolle behauptet haben, dass da falsch gezählt würde oder so.
Das war ein deutliches Zeichen dafür, dass Trump die Wahl verliert.
Die würden jetzt schon anfangen zu betrügen. Und dann kann man sagen,
naja, es war wohl kein deutliches Zeichen dafür.
Dann saß nachts im Zeit-Livestream Karolin Ehmke, die nicht davon ausging, dass Trump gewinnt.
Okay, so Einzelbeispiel kann ich jetzt nennen. Was ich aber glaube und da würde
ich sagen, da hat Wolfgang Michael vielleicht einen Punkt, ist,
dass man sich sehr in diese Vorstellung verliebt hatte, dass durch diese Popkultur,
die sehr auf Kamala Harris gegangen ist, also Brad Summer,
dann Taylor Swift's Endorsement und so weiter, dass das dazu geführt habe,
dass man ein bisschen den Blick verliert darauf, wer denn noch wählt und wer
sich einfach davon unberührt hat.
Also du gehst ja auch nicht los, nur weil du gerne André Rieu hörst und würdest
jetzt wählen, wen André Rieu wählt. Also das ist ja...
Und das ist aber sehr stark und das ist dann so eine Spiegel-Online-Berichterstattung,
die wirklich jeden, der schon mal ein Lied gesungen hat und dann gesagt hat,
ich finde Kamala Harris toll, nochmal einen eigenen Artikel gewidmet hat.
Und ich glaube, da hat man tatsächlich Fehler wiederholt aus der Clinton-Kampagne
damals, wo man auch dachte.
Naja, also wenn Jane Fonda, Oprah Winfrey und noch irgendeine Sängerin für Hillary
Clinton sind, dann ist die Wahl doch so gut wie gerettet.
Und das glaube ich ist ein generelles Phänomen und das ist vielleicht auch nochmal
verstärkt dann eines für Deutschland, weil wir so wenig von dem großen weiten Amerika kennen.
Es ist aber auch ein Problem einfach der Demokraten, dass die Demokraten sich
offenbar die Lebenswelt der anderen Amerikaner schwerlich vorstellen können.
Also das ist einfach deutlich hier auch zu sehen.
Man kann zwar gute Laune verbreiten und es war sicherlich auch nicht dumm,
das mit diesem Schlagwort weird zu machen, aber es reicht dann am Ende nicht,
wenn Kamala Harris nur anzubieten hat, dass sie nicht Donald Trump ist.
Und sie haben Umfragen gehabt zum Thema Gaza und sie haben gewusst,
dass sie damit Leute verlieren und sie haben auch gewusst, dass wenn sie sich
anders positioniert hätten, sie nicht stimmen bei denen,
die das jetzt gerade ganz gut finden, was Biden da macht, verloren hätten.
Die wären dann nicht zu Trump rübergegangen.
Da gab es Umfang. Sie wissen, wie sehr die Inflation die Menschen im Land gebeutelt hat.
Also dieses Aufstiegsding, also
diese Erfolgsgeschichte von den beiden Economics, die stimmt zum Teil.
Aber sie stimmt da nicht, wo man sagen muss, die...
Und Verbraucherpreise sind so enorm gestiegen, dass da die Lohnentwicklung bei
den unteren 50 Prozent eben nicht entsprechend mitgekommen ist.
Und die haben jetzt ein schlechteres Leben unter beiden gehabt und die können
sich auch nichts dafür kaufen, dass da die große Transformation und Inflation
Reduction Act und all das in Gang gesetzt wurden.
Und da würde ich schon sagen, ist inhaltlich einfach auch wahnsinnig viel falsch gelaufen.
Und deswegen sehe ich da schon ein Problem, wenn gerade auch die deutschen Medien
immer wieder gern den Showcharakter bei Trump zwar kritisieren,
aber bei Kamala Harris dann wirklich dankbar,
jeden, der Schauspieler ist oder Lieder singt, genommen haben,
endorsed jetzt auch Kamala Harris.
Ich will dem ganz deutlich mal widersprechen. Bitte, sag zu.
Es ist nämlich so, also in die Richtung, in die du jetzt abgebogen bist,
könnten wir wahrscheinlich aus dem Stand zehn Stunden lang über sowas reden.
Ja.
Also wer hat wo was und so weiter. Mir ging es aber konkret um,
wie ist der Journalismus damit umgegangen.
So, aus diesem, also genau diesen Kurzschluss, den will ich jetzt sozusagen
entweder entzweien, zu sagen, Spiegel Online hat darüber berichtet,
wie Taylor Swift Camilla endorsed hat.
Also hat Spiegel Online damit auch eine Präferenz für nicht nur Camilla Harris,
sondern auch, das ist ja voll cool, dass Taylor Swift das gemacht hat.
Ich freue mich so als Autor, ich schreibe das sofort auf für alle Spiegelleser.
So, jetzt kann man das kritisieren und sagen...
Nö, also das hat in diesem Journalismus gar nichts zu suchen.
Die Taylor Swift weiß ja, die erreicht ja Publikum selber. Es braucht dazu gar
keine Berichterstattung.
Ich würde da sagen, nein, nicht nur will ich alles, was zum Thema Taylor Swift
sagt, was zu Kamala Harris hat sich ja nur einmal geäußert, also gab es da drei
Texte zu, sondern ich würde es gerne in diese Taylor Lawrence Richtung drehen.
Denn Spiegel Online hätte noch viel mehr Berichterstattung machen müssen darüber,
was den Wähler bewegt. Denn es war nicht nur Taylor Swift.
Ja genau.
Die Leute haben TikTok hoch und runter.
Aber sie haben ja nur über Taylor Swift gesprochen.
Ja genau. Also die Kritik ist dann aber nicht, die haben zu viel über Taylor
Swift Bericht erstattet. Sondern nein, Spiegel Online hat für mich zu wenig
über Taylor Swift berichtet. Zu wenig über alles andere.
Also dieses ganze User-Mac, wir müssen dahin, wo die Nutzer-Augen sind.
Und ja, das ist ein ganz, wie soll man sagen, filigraner, granularer Wahlkampf.
Es gab zu wenig Berichterstattung darüber.
Deswegen verstehen wir auch heute noch nicht genau, was die Trump-Wähler bewegt hat.
Ja, eine nicht geringe Zahl von Amerikanern googelt, wer eigentlich zur Wahl steht am Tag der Wahl.
Genau, darauf kommen wir gleich nochmal.
Sowas wäre auch mal interessant.
Ja, also man kann nicht jetzt sagen, es gab zu wenig Berichterstattung zu Donald Trump.
Ich habe immer nur Texte gelesen von Taylor Swift oder was auch immer.
Ja, es gab von allem zu wenig Berichterstattung.
So und jetzt will ich hier mal kurz ein, das ist wirklich hochinteressant,
denn es gab sehr viele Podcasts seit gestern.
Also im Grunde haben alle Podcasts, die ich so abonniert habe,
haben noch mal eine Sonderfolge gemacht oder was auch immer.
Bis hin zu ein Sonderpolitik-Podcast live noch über die ARD-Audiothek gestreamt,
die 20 Uhr losging und sich eigentlich mit Trump beschäftigte.
Und dann kam aber die Ankündigung des Scholz jetzt.
Und dann wurde Scholz noch live mit in diesem Podcast gesendet und alles und Zeug.
Also es ging alles zusammen. Ich habe noch nirgendwo eine Argumentation gehört,
die ich jetzt mal kurz vortragen will.
Im Jahr 2000, George W. Bush gegen Al Gore.
Wir wissen es alle noch, das musste am Ende Florida ewig lange ausgezählt und
hat der Supreme Court einfach entschieden.
Damals stand es in absoluten Stimmen 50,9 Millionen zu 50,4 Millionen.
Das haben also knapp über 101 Millionen Menschen gewählt.
Vier Jahre später, George W. Bush gegen John Kerry, 62 Millionen zu 59 Millionen.
Es gab also auf jeder Seite plötzlich 10 Millionen Wähler mehr.
Innerhalb von vier Jahren 20 Millionen Wähler mehr.
Das ist die demografische Bewegung in Amerika.
Das ist einfach ein Einwanderungsland, ein Land mit ordentlicher Geburtenrate
und so weiter und so fort.
2008 Obama gegen John McCain.
69 Millionen gegen 59 Millionen. Also wir sind von, Al Gore hatte 50 Millionen,
auf 8 Jahre später Barack Obama hat 69 Millionen.
Das sind fast 50% mehr Wähler. 2012 wieder 65 Millionen zu 60 Millionen.
2016 65 Millionen zu 62 Millionen.
2020 Joe Biden 81 Millionen Wähler zu Donald Trump 74 Millionen Wähler.
Also wir haben ungefähr 55 Millionen mehr Wähler innerhalb von 20 Jahren. Und jetzt...
Da würde Philipp Manu zu sagen, seht ihr, die Demokratie funktioniert doch.
Das ist absolut außer Rand und Wand.
Also die Demokratie ist gar nicht in der Krise, weil das wird ja immer gesagt.
Und dann würde jetzt jemand wie Philipp Manu sagen, naja, seht ihr,
sie ist nicht in der Krise.
Aber da wurden nicht einfach nur mehr Wähler überzeugt, jetzt auch mal zur Wahl zu gehen.
Also 2000 bieten nicht einfach 55 Millionen Menschen zu Hause,
sondern die gab es einfach nicht in Amerika.
Das ist ein Land im konstanten demografischen Umbruch.
Das ist Migrationsadresse Nummer 1 für die ganze Welt.
Es ist geburtenstark, es hat innerpolitische Fliehkräfte durch Urbanisierung,
die wir hier in Europa gar nicht kennen.
So und jetzt habe ich eben gesagt, 81 Millionen Wähler für Joe Biden nach einer
stetigen Wachstumsgeschichte der demokratischen und republikanischen Wähler.
Kamala Harris fehlen 13 Millionen Stimmen im Vergleich zu Biden.
Nicht mal Donald Trump kam auf die Zahl vom letzten Mal.
Hier muss man jetzt keine Frage stellen, wo sind die Wechselwähler oder sowas.
Sind Leute nicht gegangen.
Hier gibt es keine Wechselwähler. Donald Trump hat wie vorher auch schon sein
Wählerpotenzial ausgereizt.
Es sind dieselben Leute zur Wahl gegangen wie vorher auch, nur den Demokraten
fehlen 13 Millionen Wähler.
Und wenn man sich die demografische Entwicklung anschaut, Amerika ist gewachsen.
Also wenn man das gewichtet um das demografische Wachstum, fehlen hier 16, 17 Millionen Wähler.
Ja, dieses Sagen hat eh keinen Zweck, ich bleib daheim.
Genau, wir haben es mit Desinteresse, Demobilisierung, Enttäuschung und allen
möglichen zu tun und nicht mit irgendeinem Shift zu den Republikanern oder sowas.
Nein, die Republikaner haben einfach nur Konstanten, die haben wahrscheinlich
auch Wählerschichten, die demografisch ein bisschen konstanter sind, die Demokraten nicht.
Stay in line, ja.
Genau, wir haben hier eine demografische Geschichte, die so immens und so wichtig
ist und bislang komplett ausgeblendet ist.
Also komplett ausgeblendet, nichts dazu gehört.
Und diese 13 beziehungsweise 16 Millionen, wie du dann sagst,
die jetzt Kamala Harris nicht bekommen konnte, die also zu Hause geblieben sind,
die ja nicht das Land verlassen haben,
diese, und darum ging es mir, lassen sich nicht davon locken,
dass man sagt, die und die Prominenten unterstützen Kamala Harris.
Ich würde mich sogar fragen, ob nicht auch einige Endorsements negativ sind.
Denn wenn ich sehe, dass Kamala Harris sich in der Vogue ablichten lässt,
ich werde heute einen Artikel aus der Vogue noch vorstellen,
also ich habe kein Problem mit der Vogue, aber wenn ich sehe,
okay, da ist die Vogue, dann sehe ich die Superstars, die sich mit Kamala Harris ablichten.
Dann weiß ich natürlich, ah ja, ich höre ja schon mal die Musik gerne und die wählen die.
Ich weiß aber auch, okay, das ist einfach so eine Welt der Stars,
das hat ja gar nichts mit mir zu tun.
Also die Frage ist, ob nicht diese Unterstützung dieser Stars eher einen negativen
Effekt hat, selbst bei den Leuten, die sagen, ja tendenziell finde ich Meryl
Streep gut, aber die hat ja nichts mit meiner Lebenswirklichkeit zu tun.
Was aber, und das Strukturphänomen werden wir ausführlicher dann auch betrachten,
die nächsten Jahre, denn er hat gestern darauf hingewiesen,
jetzt gerade ist auch Halbzeit der 29er oder dieser 20er Jahre,
denn klar zum Jahresende wechselt, aber wir haben im Dezember 2019 schon die
Nullnummer aufgenommen, also sind wir sozusagen auch einen Monat vorher, jetzt im November.
Es könnte durchaus sein, dass sich herausstellt, dass Donald Trumps Ansprache,
und damit meine ich jetzt das intellektuelle Niveau, das ist das Zieht, was man erreichen muss.
Das heißt, ab sofort lautet die Losung nicht mehr Aufklärung,
sondern Verpackung der richtigen Idee in der richtigen Sprache.
Und das wird die progressive, intellektuelle, wie auch immer man sie beschreibt,
Woggeschicht vor sehr große Herausforderungen stellen.
Der man sich aber stellen kann, ich erinnere daran, dass ich schon nach der
Trump-Wahl vor heute, keine Ahnung wann das war, 2016, 17 dann,
2017, bei den Formaten des Politischen war, in der Bundespressekonferenz und
das ist die Veranstaltung der Deutschlandfunkjournalisten und so weiter,
da saß also auch, Stefan Dittchen hat das moderiert, aber ich sage,
schauen sie sich die Influencer an, schauen sie sich Donald Trump an,
schauen sie sich das alles an, es geht um die Methode.
Ja.
Glauben sie nicht, es geht weiter um inhaltliche Aufklärung,
es geht um diese Methode. Wenn sie diese Methode nicht kopieren,
haben sie keinen Erfolg.
Welche Inhalte sie dann verbringen, ist völlig egal, blenden sie es aus.
Es geht erstmal um die Methode und Donald Trump hat offenbar,
so krass wir das finden, den richtigen Ton getroffen.
Das ist sehr schön, dass du das sagst, denn ich habe vergangenen Montag einen
Vortrag an der Uni Düsseldorf über,
Ideologiekritik gehalten und habe dann erstmal gesagt, was das bei Marx bedeutet,
Althusser bedeutet und dann habe ich aber auch über Realpolitisches gesprochen
und habe dann Und dann gesagt, naja,
bei Trump ist die Performance besser, habe dann so zwei Videos mal gezeigt,
einmal Kamala Harris, einmal Trump und habe gesagt, inhaltlich reden wir ja
gar nicht darüber, sondern allein die Performance.
Und dann kam danach eine sehr kluge Frage, dass es ja interessant sei,
dass ich zum einen Ideologiekritik einfordere und dass er das aufgeklärte Subjekt
meint und wenn ich aber dann über Realpolitik spreche, das so ganz instrumentell sehe.
Und sage, was funktioniert gerade? Und dann sage ich, ja, ich komme da nicht heraus.
Also ich kann natürlich sagen, ich muss jetzt, das ist ja die Idee von Schiller
in den Briefen zur ästhetischen Erziehung des Menschen.
Ich muss jetzt erst ein aufgeklärtes Subjekt herausbilden und dann ist es möglich,
die große politische Umwälzung zu machen. Ich sehe nicht, wie das gehen soll.
Ich sehe vor allem nicht, wie das bis morgen gehen soll. Also kann ich nur instrumentell
umgehen und muss auch feststellen, alle anderen haben und die US-Demokraten
haben auch schon längst, vielleicht nicht gut genug,
aber haben längst einen instrumentellen Umgang mit der Demokratie.
Wer also die Demokratie aus den Sonntagsreden nur kennt, viel Spaß dabei,
nur das hat nichts mit der Wirklichkeit zu tun.
Und deswegen muss ich dir leider zustimmen, also ich wünsche mir natürlich,
aber du wünschst es dir in dem Sinne auch, dass es eine andere Subjektivität
gibt, eine aufgeklärtere.
Aber wir müssen es in diesem instrumentellen Sinne begreifen und das heißt übrigens
nicht, dass man jetzt anfangen muss zu lügen und zu betrügen, wie Trump das tut,
sondern wir haben ja schon zum Beispiel bei Bernie Sanders jemand gesehen,
der also Menschen erreichen konnte.
Die sich jetzt nicht intellektuell mit Marx auseinandersetzen wollten oder so,
aber die wussten, dass es doch gut wäre, ein bisschen mehr Lohn zu haben und
wenn die Superreichen was abgeben müssen.
Also das heißt, diese Sprache, die dort gefunden werden muss,
ist nicht gleich eine, die pure Demagogie meint.
Ja, Trump macht uns alle dümmer, aber wir müssen nicht nur mit Blödheit darauf antworten.
Ja, da du es jetzt unter dem Label, wir bedauern das beide, will ich es nochmal
kurz ins Positive drehen.
Wenn Politik keinen Spaß macht, ist es schlechte Politik. Es muss Spaß machen.
Das heißt, man muss einen Modus finden, der nicht nur das Publikum erreicht,
sondern bei dem man versteht, warum er das Publikum erreicht,
weil er einem selber Spaß macht.
Das hätte ich gestern übrigens noch schön gefunden, wo du das sagst,
ich stimme dir voll und ganz zu, wenn Olaf Scholz gesagt hat,
das waren jetzt drei christliche Jahre, wir wollen jetzt noch ein bisschen Spaß
haben und ich lade die Union ein, mit dabei zu sein.
Genau.
Ja. Ja, ja.
Wir können jetzt wieder Spaß haben. Diese Trübsinnigkeit haben wir mit Lindner rausgeschmissen.
Es ist kein Verlust. Also wir lesen nachher das Verlustbuch.
Gut, kommen wir zu Lindner.
Bielen uns mal die Clips.
Also wir hören einfach diese editorische Notiz von Matze Hilscher selbst,
die er noch vorab veröffentlicht.
Vor dem Gespräch als Einleitung, denn die bringt uns genau auf den richtigen Track.
Während wir hier saßen, das ist jetzt die zweite Ebene, wurde im Hintergrund
sein 18-seitiges Wirtschaftswendenpapier veröffentlicht.
Und dieses Wirtschaftswendepapier ist unter Umständen, so sagt es die Zeitung,
die Welt historisch, weil es sein könnte, dass mit diesem Papier die Ampel nun
wirklich auseinanderfällt.
Und dass er hier so saß, so ganz, ganz locker und über all das gesprochen hat,
worüber wir so geredet haben und im Hintergrund so eine Bombe gezündet wird,
das finde ich wirklich irgendwie krass. Ich fand es krass, auch zum anderen,
dass er überhaupt nichts dazu gesagt hat.
Also ich glaube, hier wäre auch Rom gewesen, darüber zu sprechen.
Hätte ich zumindest sehr gerne getan.
Und dann, dass so einige Aussagen von ihm gerade...
Auch in Bezug auf Robert Habeck, jetzt ganz, ganz anders scheinen.
Also das war wirklich, wirklich besonders für mich und auch irritierend fühlte
sich irgendwie im Nachhinein oder so fühlt es sich jetzt an,
als wäre man irgendwie Teil von irgendwie so einer Haus auf Cards Folge gewesen.
Also das Haus auf Cards Ding fiel gestern in mehreren Podcast,
dass sich das so angefühlt hat.
Ja, da sitzt also einer und sagt, ich liebe meine Frau, während er selber gerade
guckt, ob die Post kam, um die Scheidungspapiere auch zu ihr zu bringen.
So ungefähr. Und ich habe den Bogen, den will ich jetzt mal so bauen,
das ist ja fast ein zweistelliges Gespräch.
Christian Lindner betont nochmal, ich bin natürlich jetzt sensibilisiert für
das Thema Familie und ich habe auch schon Merz und Scholzens Familienbild eingebaut,
nämlich Scholz, der einfach sagt, weil ich Politiker werden will,
vereinbare ich mit meiner Frau, dass wir den Kinderwunsch aus unserem Leben aussortieren.
Denn Politik und Familie ist unvereinbar.
Im Vergleich dazu, Zitate von Friedrich Merz, übrigens auch bei Matze Hilscher,
wie er sagt, als ich ins Europaparlament gewählt wurde, hatte ich schon ein Kind.
Also habe ich meiner Frau gesagt, es tut mir leid, aber ich nehme gerade den
familienfeindlichsten Beruf der Welt an. Ich hoffe, wir schaffen es.
Und das in Zitaten, also das sind sozusagen auf Zitatebene.
Und jetzt hören wir das Weltbild von Christian Lindner auf Basis dessen,
er in die Politik startet.
Also das wird man dann auch in meinem Buch nochmal nachlesen,
eingeordnet in diese anderen politischen High-Level-Familienbilder.
Mutter, die, meine Eltern haben sich ja sehr früh getrennt. Wie alt warst du da?
Da war ich vier, fünf und die mir vermittelt hat,
Wenn man irgendwie seinen Lebensstandard haben will, dann muss man auch was
können, was leisten und dann ist man unabhängig.
So, man muss was leisten, nur dann ist man unabhängig, sagt ihm seine Mutter.
Das heißt, sie reden darüber, welchen Platz findest du in der Welt.
Und dann sagt sie, du musst dich unabhängig machen und es geht über deine eigene Leistung.
Ja, also ohne Gesellschaft es versuchen zu schaffen.
Ja, so gegen die Gesellschaft.
Gegen die Gesellschaft.
Aber sozusagen, du musst einen Ego-Trip fahren.
Nur so bringst du Unabhängigkeit. Unabhängigkeit ist das Wichtigste.
Seine Mutter sagt aber zum Thema Unabhängigkeit hat sie noch eine zweite Botschaft an ihn.
Das hat mich stark geprägt. Und in Verbindung dann aber, und das ist vielleicht
noch wichtig zu, in Verbindung damit, dass meine Eltern, meine ganze Familie,
auch Großeltern, mir immer signalisiert haben, also du kannst machen,
was du willst. Wir lieben dich trotzdem.
Und das ist enorm wichtig. Warum?
Wenn du das Gefühl hast, auch wenn der Himmel über deinem Kopf zusammenbricht
und du da scheiterst mit irgendwas,
im Zweifel kannst du immer in den Schoß der Familie zurückkommen.
Die Unabhängigkeit oder die Unabhängigkeitsideologie, die eben eingeimpft wurde,
gilt also für alles, außer die Bande zur eigenen Familie.
Und das ist ja exakt der Satz von Margaret Thatcher, es gibt keine Gesellschaft,
es gibt nur Individuen und deren Familien, fügt sie an.
Es ist also die Abhängigkeit von der eigenen Familie und die Verlässlichkeit
in dieser Abhängigkeit, dort bin ich immer zu Hause.
Jetzt würde ich sagen, Politik gibt es überhaupt nur als Antwort auf das Auflösen
der Familie als zentrale Instanz.
Das ist der moderne Schritt gewesen, der Politik nötig gemacht hat.
Man konnte es nicht mehr im Familienverband lösen.
Und eine gute Politik, wie Roosevelt es dann in den 30er Jahren formulierte,
wäre eine Politik ohne Angst.
Also eine Politik, die nicht darauf setzt, dass Leute in eine permanente Furcht getrieben werden.
Eine Politik, die also dahin führt, dass wir frei von der Angst sind und damit
hin zu einer Freiheit kommen.
Was Christian Lindner hier vorstellt ist, draußen ist die feindliche Welt,
dort muss ich mich behaupten, aber ich kann mich noch auf mich als Individuum
zurückziehen oder die Familie nimmt mich in den Arm.
Aber draußen muss schon Angst herrschen und ich werde in meiner Politik alles
dafür tun, dass diese Angst auch bestehen bleibt.
Genau. Und mein Buch läuft ja auch so ein bisschen in dem Tenor,
wenn Familie ausfällt, was hier immer häufiger passiert, entweder für die Eheleute,
die sich für Familie entschieden haben oder für die Kinder, die nicht mehr auf
finanzielleres Rost zurückgreifen können oder was auch immer,
muss der Staat einspringen.
Das ist die zentrale Aufgabe der Politik, Schutznetz zu sein für diejenigen,
die das Familiäre nicht mehr vorfinden.
Wir haben es ja also nicht einfach nur mit Christian Lindner hat eine andere
Meinung oder so, sondern Christian Lindner...
Ist nicht allein mit der politischen Ideengeschichte und ihrem strukturellen
Substrat der vergangenen 800 Jahre.
Seit dem Erfolg der Städtegründung 1300.
Also im 12. Jahrhundert ging es ja so los, dass sich hier so Zentren durch die
Mobilität, so Zentren ergeben haben, wo man so Menschen begegnet,
die man nicht kennt. Und mit denen muss man trotzdem klarkommen.
Was auch bedeutet, man kennt Menschen nicht, weil man selber auch der Fremde ist.
Also man verlässt selber den eigenen Hof, um dann irgendwie 30,
300 oder weiter Kilometer entfernt Business zu machen.
So, wie verlässt man sich auf Fremde? Man hat andere Kommunikationsmedien als
einfach nur Liebe, Geborgenheit und was eher als die große Abhängigkeit von
meiner Familie, auf die ich mich immer verlassen kann.
Nee, man hat plötzlich sowas wie einen Rechtstitel, ein bisschen Geld in der Hosentasche und sowas.
Also es ist einfach völlig offensichtlich plötzlich durch diese Art von,
Christian Lindner redet mal ein Satz über seine Familie und zack wird völlig
klar, wo sein großes Missverständnis ist.
Die Rente ist ja auch etwas, was einen losmacht von der Familie.
Also dass man nicht sagen muss, ich bin gezwungen bei meinen Kindern unterm
Dach zu leben, weil ich gar kein Geld habe.
Das Rentenversprechen erlöst dich davon, 14 Kinder gebären zu müssen in deiner
Lebensphase, um sozusagen nach nigeriamischem Verhältnis, auf wen soll ich mich
verlassen? Also ich hoffe, meine Kinder haben dann einfach Berufe.
Vor allem, er beschreibt es ja selbst hier so, dass er wohl Glück hatte mit
seiner Familie und daraus muss man ja schon Schlussfolgern, dass es ja manche
dann gibt, die kein Glück mit ihrer Familie haben und die haben dann nur noch sich.
Der Staat ist es ja nicht, die Gesellschaft kann es nicht sein,
dann hat man nur noch sich als Individuum.
Blöd, dass man auch noch eine nicht taugliche Familie da hat.
Wenn du Unglück hast mit deiner Familie, begegnest du später nur noch Christian
Lindner, der dir die ganze Zeit erklärt, wie unabhängig er ist und dass du ihm egal bist.
So und jetzt schwenkt er aufgrund des Gesprächsverlaufs aber sozusagen von diesem
Familien-Ding um auf, die Ampel wird ja auch immer als Familie beobachtet,
in der kämpft er aber, weil er hat ja Ziele.
Das Ziel ist ja nicht zu sagen, jetzt komm, ich bleib stehen,
macht euer Zeug allein, sondern neu ansetzen und jetzt weiter geht's.
Und das schaffe ich. Aber was ist das dann, was dir in diesen Momenten hilft?
Also ich glaube, jeder und jede, die hier zuhört, kennt Momente des Freitag.
Es fühlt sich an wie Montag.
Mir hilft, mich zu erinnern, warum ich das mache.
Mache es, weil ich ja inhaltliche Ziele habe.
Die ich zur Not unabhängig und im Kampf gegen die anderen, weil ich mich ja
auf meine Familie verlassen kann, so jetzt mal übertrieben, einfach mein partikulares
Interesse steht über allem.
Es gibt kein Gemeinwohl, weil es gibt ja nur sozusagen die Herkunftsfamilie.
Er kann es also sehr weit treiben. Und jetzt kommt aber plötzlich er in diese
Ampelkonstellation, in der andere auch Ideen haben.
Die sie vortragen möchten, im Modus des vielleicht nicht ganz so unabhängigen
Kampfes, sondern wir machen immer Vorschläge auf was auch immer Gemeinwohlbasis,
also ich will jetzt keine Aussage über Habeck treffen,
aber Habeck hat ja Paper veröffentlicht, in denen er Vorschläge macht,
zu denen sich Lindner, wie er gleich sagt, dann nicht verhelft und während wir
das hören, erinnern wir uns, hat nicht der Matze Hilscher gerade gesagt,
der hat immer so verdächtig auf seine Uhr geguckt, was war denn da los,
der wollte gar nicht wissen, wie spät es ist, sondern was melden ihm gerade
seine Latein, wie läuft es denn mit dem Leak seines Papers und im Gespräch,
also währenddessen, ja, redet er so.
Ja, der Prozess der Klärung läuft, das ist, wir sprechen ja miteinander.
Ihr redet wirklich miteinander.
Ja, ich sag mal so, ich habe im Sommer auch ein Papier geschrieben zum Thema
Wachstum in Deutschland, aber ich habe das im Sommer nicht veröffentlicht.
Robert Habeck hat seins veröffentlicht und es gab erst die völlig legitime Idee
des Kanzlers zu einem Pakt für Industriearbeitsplätze und er spricht ohne Herrn
Habeck und mich jetzt mit Unternehmen,
Verbänden und Gewerkschaften,
habe ich nicht als erster die Idee entwickelt.
Und insofern ist die Lage jetzt da und die Lage wird jetzt aufgelöst werden müssen.
Also diesen Clip alleine finde ich schon hammerhart, aber diese 14 Sekunden hier.
Nochmal, warum passiert das so öffentlich? Und da machst du ja genauso mit wie
die anderen im Grunde auch.
Bisher habe ich noch nicht auf Robert Habecks Papier mit einem eigenen Papier
geantwortet. Am 1. November.
Während er sein eigenes Papier gerade legt. In der Sekunde.
Aber in dem Moment funktioniert die Lüge noch und deswegen sagt man sie.
Also soweit darf man Unabhängigkeit einfach nicht treiben. Soweit darf man das
Gemeinwohl, und wir kommen nachher im Salon drauf, es gibt ja auch ein neues
Buch von den Assmanns, Jan und Aleida Assmann, zum Thema Gemeinsinn.
Wir kommen darauf zurück.
Soweit darf man einfach den Gemeinsinn nicht austreiben.
Dass man wirklich nur noch seine eigene, ich kämpfe das jetzt so,
ich rede so, während ich zeitgleich ganz anders handel.
Ja, wie gesagt, wir brauchen über Trump nicht mehr dann zu reden.
Also wir brauchen, nur weil Trump ein bisschen komisch aussieht und ein bisschen
laut ist, brauchen wir jetzt nichts zu tun, als sei das eine andere Kategorie.
Nein, das ist so. Wer mit Lindner spricht, spricht mit Trump.
Und jetzt möchte er den Grünen noch eine Idee des Arbeitsmodus austreiben.
Ja, aber das übereinander reden, das macht ihr ja alle. Also vor allen Dingen Habeck und du.
Nö, also natürlich, aber... Aber du weißt ja, wie das wirkt.
Das ist ja eigentlich, ich sage ja, also das ist als würden,
steht vor der Klasse stehen drei Lehrer, die sich vor der Klasse streiten.
Naja Matze, die Grünen haben gesagt, das ist eine Übergangsregierung.
Der Kandidat für den grünen Parteivorsitz sagt, es sei gerade die Koalition
so wie ein Ehepaar im Trennungsjahr oder man ist nur noch zusammen wegen der Kinder.
Und da sagt er, nein, wir sind hier keine Ehe, wir sind hier keine Familie.
Ich habe meine Familie, wir sind hier im unabhängigen Kampf,
jeder gegen jeden, jeder für sich.
Und der macht alles richtig.
Ja, also wirklich selten hat man eine Ideologie.
Und man sieht ja hier an dem Moderator, an Matze, dass er bemüht ist, ihn zu verstehen.
Und er macht jedes Angebot, dass man, also wir könnten ja so ein Gespräch gar
nicht führen, wir würden ja nach drei Minuten Lindner auslachen und sagen, verschwinde.
Aber Matze macht das zwei Stunden da und wird einfach nur verarscht.
Und sagt das ja auch am Anfang, deswegen hat er ja diese lange Einleitung,
der sagt also, eigentlich ist ja sein Tenor am Anfang, Leute,
ich habe schon viele Gespräche geführt, aber sowas noch nie.
Er fragt ja immer, ich will wissen, wie Leute ticken, so sagt das ja auch in
Gesprächspartnern. Er will also das Innermenschliche.
An das traut er sich jetzt hier schon gar nicht mehr ran, aber er fragt nochmal
nach diesem Zwischenmenschlichen.
Nicht so, dass die menschlichen Beziehungen in der Regierung irgendwie nicht
intakt wären, dass man nicht miteinander sprechen könnte.
Das ist ein falscher Eindruck, weil du bist Rezipient von Medien.
Aber wenn ich das mit aller Vorsicht sagen darf, es steht zum Teil auch einfach,
ich würde fast sagen Erfundenes oder Gerüchtemäßiges in den Zeitungen und deshalb
würde ich sagen, es gibt keine menschlichen,
zwischenmenschlichen Hürden für kluge Ergebnisse.
Sagt derjenige, der gestern den gesamten Tag der Bild-Zeitung durchgestochen
hat und zwar im Minutentakt wohl.
Also eigentlich hat die FDP gestern den Live-Ticker der Bild-Zeitung geschrieben.
Aber sonst geht man respektvoll miteinander um und was die Medien schreiben, ist oft Quatsch.
Die Bild hatte ja auch zwischenzeitlich so eine Überschrift,
irgendwie so 17 Milliarden Futsch, Lindner scheitert mit Papier und so.
Das ist ja auch völlig neben der Spur. Letzter Clip hierzu, er ist die ganze
Zeit von seiner Uhr abgelenkt, wurde aber gefragt, warum bist du eigentlich Finanzminister?
Der Finanzministerposten, das ist ja wahrscheinlich der Posten,
der dir ich weiß, ich fahre gerade nach Hause, das ist das Gespräch,
Entschuldigung, das war jetzt sehr offensichtlich das liegt auf die Uhr,
sorry Der Finanzministerposten ist ja eigentlich der Posten,
der wahrscheinlich gemacht ist für dich würde ich behaupten,
Also wo man sagt, ich mach's gern Es.
Macht ihm Spaß Also ich bin sehr dafür Journalisten sollten immer mal Politiker
fragen, ob ihnen das gerade Spaß macht.
Weil die Antwort darauf kann vielsagend sein.
Weil ich auch meine, es sollte Spaß machen.
Ein Kampf gegen alle darf keinen Spaß machen. Wer behauptet,
das macht ihm Spaß, muss leider aus,
Devianzgründen entfernt werden aus dem Amt. Wenn Christian Lindner hier am Fazit
so eines Gesprächs nochmal betont, wie viel Spaß was ihm das macht.
Und wir haben aber gerade gehört, was er da macht. Müssen wir sagen, nein.
Also das darf einfach prinzipiell nicht sein. Ich bin jetzt nicht dafür,
dass man die Kandidaten zwischen Wahl und Annahme der Wahl nochmal in den psychologischen
Test, aber ich neige immer mehr dazu.
Sowas einzufordern.
Es muss journalistisch begleitet werden, was hier los ist. Also wenn die Leute
zu sozial gestört sind, also echte Störungsbilder zeigen.
Und ich meine nicht die psychologische Diagnose, die natürlich nur psychologische Dienste machen können.
Aber wenn wir als interessiertes Publikum bei unseren Staatsdienern solche Devianzen
feststellen, muss das thematisiert werden.
Ich befürchte allerdings, dass es nicht thematisiert werden wird und ich befürchte
auch, dass eine Normalisierung dieser Devianz stattfindet.
Die Union geht schon in eine ähnliche Richtung.
Auch bei der FDP gab es einmal mehr vernünftige Stimmen und ich bin weit davon
entfernt, die FDP an sich zu loben.
Aber es gab sie durchaus und es gab liberale, kluge Menschen,
die bereit waren, sich auf ein Argument einzulassen und nicht dieses deviante
Verhalten nur an den Tag legt.
Und wenn ich jetzt auf die Wahl blicke in den USA, wo Trump wieder gewählt wurde
und wir Äußerungen haben, wie zum Beispiel von Ursula von der Leyen,
die nicht nur gratuliert, sondern gleich nochmal betont, wie stark die transatlantische
Partnerschaft sein soll und all das,
dann merke ich, dass eine Normalisierung der Devianz eigentlich stattfindet
und man sich dann auch irgendwann fragen muss, wohin führten das noch alles?
Also wir können ja jetzt nicht mit Trump gemeinsam sagen, kämpfen wir für die
liberale Demokratie, gegen die Autokratien. Ja, das ist ja wie mit PDD für Frauenrechte
kämpfen. Das kann ja nicht gehen.
Was auch stattfindet demnächst, glaube ich.
Wahrscheinlich kommt das auch noch. Elon Musk wird dann versuchen,
PDD zu rehabilitieren oder was auch immer.
Also das heißt, da sehe ich, dass das immer mehr in diese Richtung sich bewegt.
Und ich finde, dass hier auch mal wirklich eine Selbstkritik stattfinden sollte
von gerade der Ampel, auch von den Grünen,
dass man diesen Protektionismus, den Biden abverlangt hat, so klar mitgemacht hat.
Denn jetzt haben wir da ein Nest gebaut für Donald Trump, wo er seine Zölle
noch weiter auf errichten kann.
Und ob man nicht ein bisschen klüger gefahren wäre, hätte man sich mehr mit
Macron beschäftigt und überlegt, wie man klug eine Handelspolitik und auch eine
Freihandelspolitik gestaltet.
Da fällt uns jetzt ganz viel auf die Füße.
Ursula von der Leyen sagte damals, als Biden ins Amt gewählt wurde,
America is back und Macron war derjenige, der sich traute im Beisein des Präsidenten
zu sagen, fragt sich nur wie lange.
Und diese Frage ist jetzt die, die beantwortet ist, für kurz war es nur.
Ja, also du hast so einen Drang zu den Inhalten.
Ja, nur ein bisschen Inhalte wollen wir noch machen.
Ich habe auch mich gefreut.
Dass Trump nochmal bei MCA performt hat, aber das kann ja nicht alles sein.
Ich hatte ja schon beim Blick auf Merz darauf hingewiesen, Merz wird jetzt gewählt,
er ist der Kanzler der nächsten vier Jahre, sich dagegen aufzunehmen,
wir müssen jetzt diese anderen Fragen stellen. Was ist in 15 Jahren?
Und als Arbeitsauftrag an die Journalisten, sie müssen sich jetzt darüber verständigen
und sei es nur mit sich, warum machen sie diesen Beruf und was fasziniert sie
so an dem Gegenstand, die sie beobachten?
Und es sind nicht die Inhalte, sondern sie sind fasziniert von der Macht,
von der Devianz, die sie nicht verstehen, von diesem Tatendrang,
von der Arbeitswut, die da beobachtet wird.
Ich würde sozusagen jetzt der Connex oder der Nexus, der jetzt zu betrachten
ist, warum wird Donald Trump gewählt, warum wird Christian Lindner gefeuert,
warum geht Kevin Kühnert freiwillig,
warum tritt die grüne Jugend aus, das ist ein Thema.
An verschiedenen Problemen, an verschiedenen Ausprägungen, aber das ist ein
Thema und das muss jetzt betrachtet werden, weil wenn wir einfach nur weiter,
die Eile gebietet nicht, dass wir jetzt reflektieren, sondern wir müssen Bericht
erstatten, was ist und dann schmeißen alle ihre Podcast-Mikrofone an und erklären hier.
Das ist ja jetzt auch, dass man dann sagt, naja, aber da hatte Lindner ja schon
einen Punkt mit der Schuldenbremse. So waren ja schon gestern wieder Berichte.
Also mich interessieren jetzt andere Sachen und ich finde, alle Leute sollten
jetzt sozusagen diese Meta-Ebene mal einnehmen, weil da geht es auch interessant zu.
Da erfährt man einiges und vielleicht ist dieser Matze Hilscher gar nicht so
falsch. er psychologisiert viel, aber so kann man es auch soziologisieren,
die sozialen Phänomene da anschauen und dem sollte man jetzt mal,
etwas direkter, expliziter nachgehen.
Wir sind auf jeden Fall durch dieses Gespräch der Ideologie und dem Wesen von
Christian Lindner näher gekommen, als durch all seine Talkshow-Auftritte. Und das heißt ja etwas.
Wir verweisen jetzt auf den Salon. Wer diesen Podcast unterstützen will,
kann in den Salon kommen und bekommt da natürlich auch was.
Nämlich wir diskutieren Neuerscheinungen. Immer einmal im Monat sprechen wir
über ein wichtiges Sachbuch und außerdem stellt dann jeder von uns noch fünf
wichtige Texte des Monats vor,
beziehungsweise ich stelle vier Texte vor und habe wieder einen Hörtipp, es gibt wieder Musik,
wir wollen ja nicht ganz verzweifeln, also hören wir uns gute Musik an,
das gibt es dann auch wieder.
Worüber sprechen wir aber ausführlich heute oder worüber werden wir viel mehr diskutieren?
Verlust, ein Grundproblem der Moderne von Andreas Reckwitz.
Andreas Reckwitz ist der Soziologe, den auch alle Politiker lesen,
zum Beispiel Friedrich Merz oder auch Robert Habeck.
Er hat jetzt ein Buch über den Verlust geschrieben als etwas,
was gerade in der Moderne und Spätmoderne wahnsinnig präsent ist.
Er fächert das auf. Wir werden diskutieren, ob diese Soziologie uns weiterhilft
oder ob wir mit dem Wort nochmal was ganz anderes machen müssen.
Wir sind auch gute, inspirative Leser. Wir müssen nicht jeden Autor für voll nehmen.
Das werden wir also diskutieren. Es ist auf jeden Fall ein Dokument unserer
Zeit, dem wir uns stellen.
Ich werde dann, wie gesagt, eine CD vorstellen. Streichquartett gibt es da.
Dann eine französische Autorin schreibt einen ganz schmalen Roman über einen
jungen Russen, Aljoscha, der eingezogen wird in Deutschland.
Zum Militärdienst, aber nicht will. Und er trifft dann in der transsibirischen
Eisenbahn auf eine wohlhabende Französin.
Und dann ändert sich da manches.
Dann habe ich das Buch Fehldiagnose, wie Ökonomen die Wirtschaft ruinieren und
die Gesellschaft spalten, gelesen von dem Ökonomen Tom Krebs.
Das ist sehr interessant und ich will nur mal die Aspekte Reallohnverlust und
Inflation herausarbeiten, denn das macht der Autor sehr, sehr gut.
Außerdem noch ein Text über die Polymarkets, also es wird ja jetzt gewettet,
wer wird der nächste Präsident, das wissen wir jetzt inzwischen.
Oder auch, wann wird Nasrallah getötet?
Geht Israel da und dorthin? Was passiert politisch da und dort als nächstes?
Viele Millionen sind da im Spiel und wir sehen dann auch, wer da alles investiert
ist, zum Beispiel auch Peter Thiel.
Und es wird noch einen kurzen Text über einen TikTok-Trend zum Thema Schlafen geben.
Sehr gut. Der Chefe von Anthropic, und ich bin ja ein großer Fan seiner Technik,
hat Dario Amodai, heißt er, hat früher bei OpenAI und jetzt ist er Chefe von
Anthropic, hat einen 10.000 Worte lang Text darüber geschrieben, was zu erwarten ist.
Wir dürfen den auch nicht vervollnehmen, aber wir müssen uns kurz verständigen, was da drin steht.
Dann dieses, ja, vorher naive Kampfpapier, würde ich sagen, würde,
aber jetzt anscheinend Übergangsbrückentechnologie, politische Brückentechnologie der drei Beraterchefs.
Dazu zwei Texte, ich will mal zwei nennen, um sozusagen, das eine ist eine Befassung
mit, worum geht es emotional bei der amerikanischen Wahl.
Und dann ein zweiter Text, Worum geht es politisch?
Den will ich aber nur kurz nennen, den muss wirklich jeder selber lesen und
ich werde auch sagen, warum, also aus welcher Quelle er empfohlen wurde.
Das ist, wie soll man sagen, da stellen einem sich so ein bisschen die ängstlichen
Nackenhaare auf und am Ende eine Buchempfehlung eines Buches,
das ich nicht gelesen habe, sondern es handelt von klassischer Musik.
Und es ist so konzipiert, wie klassische Musik konzipiert ist.
Man setzt sich nicht hin und hört sich zehn Konzerte auf einmal an,
sondern man geht punktuell rein.
Und hier ist besonders interessant, wer dieses Buch geschrieben hat,
denn wir haben ihn schon ein paar Mal erwähnt und man hätte nicht glauben können,
dass jetzt plötzlich klassische Musik hier Thema ist. Aber gut.
Ich bin sehr gespannt darauf.
Sehr gespannt.
Ich möchte noch kurz ankündigen, dass ich am, ich glaube 13.11.
Ist es, ja am 13.11. in Koblenz zu erleben bin.
Da halte ich einen Vortrag über die kommenden Klassenkämpfe und das gute Leben.
Am 17.11. bin ich im Filmmuseum Frankfurt und am 20.11. bin ich an der Uni Köln.
Da geht es um die kleinen Holzdiebe.
Weitere Termine, ich bin auch noch Anfang Dezember in Zürich,
alles auf meiner Homepage wolfgangmschmidt.de. und jetzt musst du noch erklären,
wie man dann in den Salon kommt.
Der kostet ja 3 Euro im Monat, dann ist man dabei.
Neue 20er.de, wir sind ein Podcast mit Webseite, über die läuft alles wie auch
der goldene Button in den Salon.
Am besten folgt man dem einfach, dann ist man Best Daddy, macht sich einen Account
und bucht. Man bekommt dann alles.
Also inzwischen 9 und ne warte mal, wir sind ja jetzt wirklich bei 60 5 Jahre mal 12.
Also wir sind tatsächlich bei fast 60 Salons.
Mehr als 50 Bücher, die wir gemeinsam besprechen. Hunderte Bücher,
die einzeln besprochen werden.
Da kann man alles nachhören. Oder bei Patreon, nicht das ganze Archiv,
aber die aktuellen Folgen.
Oder bei Apple, die allerkürzeste Ein-Klick-Lösung. Wenn man eh schon 29er bucht, macht man es einfach da.
Außerdem heute im Salon, wir nennen die vier Termine für die CASE nächstes Jahr.
Da kann man dann direkt buchen. Also wir verkaufen wieder alle Tickets auf einmal.
Das Jahr wird also relativ zügig jetzt gleich wegverkauft.
Prima, dann sehen wir uns im Salon.
Bis gleich.